hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to the
tim ferriss show
where it is my job every episode to
deconstruct world
class performers of all different types
to tease out the habits routines
favorite books
who knows what that you can hopefully
emulate or apply
in your own lives my guest today is none
other than
scott kelly at station cdr kelly
on twitter and elsewhere scott is a
former
military fighter pilot and test pilot
and engineer a retired astronaut and
retired u.s navy captain
a veteran of four space flights kelly
commanded the international space
station iss
on three expeditions and was a member of
the year-long mission aboard the iss
the single longest space mission by an
american astronaut
in october 2015 he set the american
record for the total accumulated number
of days spent in space
go for launch how to dream lead and
achieve
is kelly's two-hour audio course
available exclusively on
knowable in this candid and entertaining
audio course scott shares instructive
stories from his childhood new jersey
his days as a u.s navy test pilot and
his year
hurdling around the globe at 17 500
miles per hour
and teaches hard-earned lessons on
perseverance personal motivation and the
human side of success drawn from his
experiences in the most competitive
extreme environments imaginable you can
find it now at
knowable that's k n o w a b
l e dot f y i forward slash scott you
can find him on
social twitter instagram facebook at
stationcdr kelly
and before we jump into the interview i
want to play you one lesson from scott's
audio course the lesson is titled the
smartest person on the mission and it
really highlights
decision making under pressure a
superpower of his
also after the interview ends i'll share
two more of scott's lessons
so be sure to stick around
[Music]
sometimes in space you get a call from a
third grade classroom that wants to see
what it looks like to go to the bathroom
in zero gravity
other times you get a call from mission
control saying there's a hole the size
of a golf ball
in the heat shield and you might burn up
on re-entry
i got that call a day or so into
commanding my first
and only space shuttle mission a similar
issue had killed
seven of my colleagues on columbia a few
years earlier
we could do a spacewalk to try to repair
the heat shield
but spacewalks are extremely risky on
their own
and there was always a danger we could
just damage the heat shield more while
trying to fix it
[Music]
but if we left the hole as it was the
heat of re-entry might tear the space
shuttle apart
as commander i had a lot of say in what
our approach was going to be
it would have been tempting to make a
quick decision on my own
but over the years i've spent leading
and following i've learned that the best
decisions aren't made that way
instead i found a good time to take each
crew member aside
one by one in private i kept a picture
of the heat shield damage and a printout
of some analysis from the ground in my
back pocket
so i'd be able to take advantage of a
quiet moment
i made sure i spoke to each of my crew
members individually to get their honest
opinions
i took this to such an extreme that i
asked everyone i could
i even asked the astronaut and russian
cosmonauts who weren't coming back with
us on endeavor why not call a meeting
why not make a decision together as a
group well
i've seen what can happen when people
try to make decisions in groups
one person will offer an opinion and if
that person is knowledgeable or well
respected
everyone else might go along with what
they said
group think sets in people aren't even
conscious of doing this sometimes
it's something we do as a social species
to get along
and it's often a useful instinct but in
a case like this
it could be deadly there's a sign
on the wall in a meeting room at nasa
none of us
is as dumb as all of us and it's a
lesson nasa had to learn the hard way
it's part of what went wrong with the
columbia accident and with challenger
before it
people who raised concerns were silenced
because group think had taken over
with the input of my crew and after
thorough analysis we decided along with
flight controllers and leaderships on
the ground
that coming back with the hole in the
heat shield posed
less of a risk than attempting a repair
right mainland
the gouge goes pretty much through the
entire thickness of the
tile itself is 1.2 inches thick
we fired the deorbit engines
and as we came out of darkness and
started hitting the atmosphere
the plasma field the fire outside the
space shuttle
continued to build pretty soon we were
in a 3000 degree fireball
falling towards earth at an incredible
speed
me and my entire crew were mostly silent
as we approached the point
where the space shuttle columbia had
come apart
as we transitioned through that altitude
my pilot scorch said
passing through pekidi understand i
replied
i let about 20 seconds go by and added
looks like we dodged that bullet as we
all reflected on the loss of our seven
colleagues
[Music]
about 30 minutes later we landed safely
at the kennedy space center in florida
but this kind of decision making can
help in other places too
places like a level one trauma center in
tucson arizona
when my sister-in-law congresswoman
gabrielle giffords was shot in 2011
i was in space halfway through a
six-month mission
my brother mark was constantly having to
make difficult decisions about her care
he found himself in meetings with many
of her caretakers trauma surgeons
brain surgeons neurologists but instead
of just hearing out the top doctor or
more experienced expert
mark would go a step further he would
find one quiet person in the back of the
room and asked them who they were
i'm just an intern they might say or i'm
just a nurse
but mark didn't care what the person's
training was what do you think he would
ask
what are we missing what are we
overlooking even if they hadn't been
there long
their opinion mattered and he learned
valuable information by gathering as
many perspectives as he could
i learned as much as seeing from how he
handled gabby's care as i did from
anyone i flew with in space
[Music]
the smartest person in the room i've
learned
is usually the person who knows how to
tap into the intelligence
of every person in the room
this episode is brought to you by rock
form that's without a c
r o k f o r m rokform is the active
lifestyle
iphone and galaxy protective case
company i've been using their stuff
for a few months now and good god
they can survive anything first off
rokform protection is beyond great you
can find thousands of five-star reviews
and customer testimonials which the team
at rock farm calls survival stories that
include
things like a drop from the upper deck
of a baseball stadium and a 75 foot cell
phone tower fall
it's kind of unbelievable but these
cases make your phone
virtually indestructible each case is
built also around an integrated magnet
that is completely
safe for your phone the magnets are
incredibly strong
and allow you to instantly attach your
device to any magnetic surface
toolboxes file cabinets refrigerators
golf carts
you name it i use it in the gym to check
my form a lot of the time you can just
slap it on just about anything rokform
pioneered magnetic technology in the
mobile accessory space in 2011
and i've never seen anything quite like
these magnets
i will use mine on my pellets on bikes
so i can watch listen or take calls
during workouts
it fits my iphone 11 pro max perfectly
and allows me to keep my hands free for
all sorts of stuff
all their cases also come with a
built-in twist lock system that can be
used with any of rokform's optional
mounts
for bike motorcycle car and much more
these machined aluminum mounts are built
to last and are compatible with every
rokform case
so if you get a new phone or whatever
you just need a new
case and it will still attach to all of
the mounts
rokform also has a portable golf speaker
this is bluetooth
that instantly mounts to a golf cart
with mind-blowingly
strong magnets like i mentioned i don't
really golf
but i will use this bluetooth speaker to
listen to music
in the kitchen i'll slap it on the
refrigerator i will
use it in the gym and hang it from a
carabiner which is included
with the speaker and so on and so forth
so
upgrade to a rokform case today because
you have better things to hold on to you
can use your hands for other stuff
and like i mentioned these things make
your phone bulletproof
and as a special offer for tim ferris
show listeners that's you guys
get 25 off that is a good discount 25
off at rockform.com that's rokform.com
when you use promo code tim that's 25
off
at rokform.com when you use promo code
tim one more time rockform.com promo
code
tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs the global creative platform
that makes it easy for you to find and
work with amazing graphic designers
online
longtime listeners of this podcast know
how much attention i paid to detail
how obsessively i approach nearly all
elements of my work
because the small things often end up
being the big things so whether it's
your logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about
so i think it's worth sweating the
details i've been using 99designs for
years now to ensure that many of my
creative projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer at 99designs to update the
illustrations and layouts for all of my
downloadable ebooks i've developed a
really great working relationship with
the designer who goes by
the username spoon lancer and i intend
to continue working with him to bring
ideas to life one project at a time
i've also used 99 designs for all sorts
of
high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long-term work you can also book a
free design consultation with a brand
expert at
99designs to receive personalized
branding advice over the phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point it's a
great way to get the most out of your
experience with 99designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com
tim for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation today
that's 99designs.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
[Music]
[Music]
scott welcome to the show thanks for
having me tim and
i wanted to start not with space but
with
west orange new jersey in i suppose the
60s
and your mom specifically could you
please speak
to your mom's experience with
joining the police force well that's a
that's a good place to start
with my mom because we all started with
our moms
and really this this all happened kind
of in the late 70s
and throughout the 80s where my dad was
a cop
in new jersey and he was in my hometown
of west orange
he was one of those like stereotypical
like irish cop guys you'd see on tv
and uh my mother was a secretary and a
waitress
various jobs she had at different times
and about the time my brother and i were
becoming teenagers when she could
spend more time at work she decided that
she wanted to have a career like my
father's and
was going to attempt to become a police
officer in our hometown
had never had a female police officer
before at the time there were very few
in the state of new jersey you know it
was a challenging thing for her
especially the physical part of it
because
you know at that time it was a physical
fitness test was really designed for the
men that were
trying to become you know policemen and
firefighters to civil service exams that
included
physical fitness portion and it was a a
challenge that for her was not easy but
you know i saw her work really really
hard at this
and you know my dad helped her by
setting up this obstacle course in her
backyard and
you know when she first went out there
she was not very successful and
you know i was a little bit skeptical i
can remember thinking is she gonna
really be able to do this but
she uh you know she had a goal that she
wanted to achieve a plan to get there
and uh she was successful and it was the
first time in my life that i
i saw the uh the power of having this
goal you think
you might not be able to achieve a plan
to get there and then
working really really hard at something
i always wanted to thank my mom
for giving that lesson to me and and my
brother mark
is it true that the family or
she built a mock-up
wall in the backyard to practice
climbing over
in preparation for the police exam
yeah like i was saying my dad helped her
and he built the whole
all this the activity she would have to
do in her in her backyard including a
wall
that was seven foot four inches tall he
actually built it an inch taller without
telling her so she thought she was
practicing on a
you know a seven foot four inch wall and
she was practicing on one that was an
inch taller
my dad thinking that might help her on
the on the real day
when she had the scale this thing that
she would be
overly prepared yeah the first time she
went to climb over that
she probably got her foot a foot high
and
fell off fell back into the dirt but i
can remember picking herself up
you know brushing herself off and you
know just saying
i'm gonna just try to touch the top for
now
and then you know once i can do that
i'll see how long i can hold on for
maybe someday eventually i'll be able to
do a pull-up
and quite possibly at the end of the
summer perhaps be able to get over this
wall
you know some of the other tests was she
had to drag a 130 pound dummy
100 feet and we just happened to have a
long backyard
i happened to at the time weigh 130
pounds
and also fit the role as a dummy because
i wasn't particularly good at school so
yeah so with my help and a summer of
really hard work on her part and when
she went to
to take that test she uh actually did
better than a lot of the men did and
became the very first female police
officer in my hometown one of the first
in the entire state
she was off to the races you you just
mentioned school and that's
that's where i want to go next i think
that many people listening
have a certain i suppose archetypal
narrative that they would impose
on astronauts in terms of life story and
they see
star students knocking it out of the
park knowing from the age of three they
want to be in space
etc you mentioned you weren't
necessarily the best in school my
understanding is you graduated in the
bottom half
of your high school class and
had various sort of misadventures along
the way
what happened in terms of course
correction if there was a particular
course correction it was their point at
which
you learned to study was there a
catalyzing event
for you that reoriented your focus yeah
so you know most people would
would think as an astronaut you must
have been the smartest guy in the class
the overachiever
and that is certainly the case with a
lot of my colleagues i mean i know
folks that i've worked with that saw
neil armstrong
walk on the moon and when they were
little kids and decided right then and
there that's what they were going to do
and they did the best at everything from
there on out until they became an
astronaut and was flying it were flying
in space
which is great i wish i could have done
that i think it's kind of a boring story
though i think it's much more
interesting when it's
someone like me who couldn't pay
attention in school
i spent probably the first uh 13 years
of my education
staring out the window winning when is
this going to be over
so i can get out of here and it was
felt like it was impossible for me when
i was a kid to pay attention
it's not like i didn't want to i always
went
into the new school year with the
intention of doing well
and three days into school i'd be three
days behind and then
the rest of the year was just basically
on autopilot
not really learning much not paying
attention a whole lot
not getting good grades i think back
then it seemed like it was easier to do
that
then i think what i've noticed with my
kids today
i don't think you'd be able to get away
with you know the amount of effort i put
in then
but i could just remember it being
impossible for me to pay attention
basically having the feeling that if you
would have
held a gun to my head to force me to pay
attention
i wouldn't have been able to do it
that's how i felt and i think you know i
probably have like
80d or adhd never diagnosed
so that's probably why i had such a hard
time
and it wasn't until i got to college and
i was still uh
you know still struggling i didn't know
how to study
really didn't do well eventually i'm not
even going to class
anymore or at least much
basically you know on the fast track of
how a lot of kids experience their first
year of college you know basically one
and done
you know one year and and you're done
and then i was just walking across the
college campus
just happened to walk into the bookstore
uh not to buy a book i was probably
you know going there to buy gum or some
other non-educational
related thing
maybe they sold beer there i don't know
who knows
but i i remember seeing this book on the
end of the aisle you know where they
highlight
the stuff that they're trying to sell i
think it's called like the end cap
or something of a bookshelf and
you know there's this book that had this
pretty patriotic red white and blue
cover
a cool title caught my eye
made me pick it up wasn't a big reader
at the time so it's kind of unusual for
me to
actually buy a book like that then and
i read the back found it interesting
looked through the first few pages
took my gum money or my beer money or
whatever it was and uh
bought the book walked back to my dorm
room
and then uh opened it up and basically
didn't get out of my bed for the next
few days
just reading the stories of the fighter
pilots
military fighter pilots and test pilots
that became the original mercury gemini
and apollo astronauts and
the book was the right stuff by tom wolf
you know something in that book just
really sparked my imagination i think
it's probably partly his uh creative
non-fiction
writing style that was just really
caught my attention and my imagination
it was the fact that i felt like i could
relate to the
people in the book the guys that were
he was writing about they were all guys
at the time not anymore and you know
they're
obviously a lot of female astronauts now
but back then there was only men
and felt like i had something in common
with them
and you know with regards to like
risk taking and putting myself in
challenging and risky situations uh
you know the the adventure of it really
spoke to me but then i realized
i am not a good student and these guys
you know most of them went to the
military service academies i think pete
conrad went to
went to princeton i mean they were very
accomplished uh students before they
were pilots
but i thought to myself you know if i
could just fix that one thing about
me you know if i could learn how to
pay attention and study and do better in
school
perhaps i could change colleges change
majors become a
get an engineering major the place i was
at wasn't quite working out for me and
get a commission in the u.s navy and go
fly
fighter planes off of an aircraft
carrier
maybe become a test pilot maybe quite
possibly an astronaut someday
so you know that inspiration i think is
important that's what i tell
kids that also a lot of parents you know
if their kids are struggling i think
you can tell them all you want that they
have to do better but you really have to
show them
why they need to do better you know
there has to be that thing that
inspiration
that spark that just provides
inspiration to get people moving in the
right direction
that's what tom wolf's right stuff was
for me and later
you shot him an email from space with a
photograph of yourself with that book
if i am getting my facts straight which
just
is such a an incredible full
cycle to return to the origin in a sense
and uh incredible prose writer
as you noted just a wonderful craftsman
of
of non-fiction what happened or what
did you change after that inspiration
was it valuable
because it aligned your academic focus
in a way where you were simply choosing
courses that were more
oriented towards that path and that is
what helped you
to then find a different
sort of vector of of progress was it
just despite your difficulties with
attention
was it just doubling down because now
you had a better reason
what changed well hey let me just
comment first on you were you mentioning
the
that email which his response was so
tom wolf-like in that he had words in
there
that were not really words
and outrageous punctuation so
it was pretty cool email to get back
from him but
you know in my case it wasn't really
focusing on like new subjects that
more more in line with being an engineer
or pilot because those were really the
subjects i had the most
challenge with like math as an example i
wasn't really a great
math student or actually i wasn't great
at anything
but for me it wasn't necessarily like a
change of course or like you said a
vector or doubling
it was more than doubling down on the
fact that no matter how hard i've tried
in the past that didn't work
and i just have to try a lot harder to
force myself
to learn how to learn really was
the first challenge of the next year
after i read tom's book and i decided
that this is what i'm going to do
i um yeah i just had to do it
kind of brute force method by myself i
think today
you would have a lot more help
especially if you have
diagnosed atd or adhd it would be there
would be
ways to get support and assistance but
for me strictly the brute force method
like
chain myself to my desk don't move until
i can
figure out how to do this pre-calculus
problem i remember that being a big
struggle at the
school i was at but eventually you know
like like many things you know what i
what i've always found in my career
whether it's in the military in the navy
you know flying airplanes whether it's
at nasa
and that is how good we are when we
start something
is not related at all to how good we can
become at anything
when did you first and maybe you just
had the confidence from the get-go
after reading tom's book was there a
point
after you chain yourself to the desk you
double and triple down with this brute
force method
was there a particular point where you
thought to yourself
i can actually do this i
i believe that i can forge a path that
will take me
to where i want to go well i don't know
if confidence is the right word i don't
i've i've always felt that kind of like
a below average guy
performing at an above average level and
i think that's a good place to be
because if you get too confident i think
you get lazy
and you know once i figured out what i
needed
to do i always felt like i
needed to work harder than other people
because
maybe i didn't have as much natural
smarts or talent or ability
so there was never a moment where i ever
got confident
there was kind of a turning point and
that is
from a learning and education
perspective and that is
eventually i figured out how to study
well enough that i was able to change
schools i changed
majors i became an engineering major but
now i'm starting my freshman year all
over again but still haven't really
cracked the code on what it takes
it was coming up on columbus day i went
to a school called the state university
in new york maritime college it's in the
bronx
it's a college that has a military
regimental system which i
felt like i had to have that so that was
the primary reason i went there
the other reason was it was really one
of the few places i could get into
because i had such bad high school
grades and my first year college grades
weren't all that great but i needed that
kind of discipline and structure i felt
like i did
my brother who was on a completely
different trajectory
once we went into high school was at the
u.s merchant marine academy
and asked me a little bit later how he
became on a upon a different trajectory
because it's actually kind of a funny
story but he was across the river
actually the long island sound at the
u.s merchant marine academy and he's he
was a year
wound up a year ahead of me because i i
took that first year
mulligan on college
well we were coming up on columbus day
weekend so it's kind of the beginning of
the school year almost
and i call my brother up and i say hey
some of our our friends are having a uh
a frat party at rutgers some of our high
school friends
and i was thinking of going there for
the whole weekend you know leave on
friday come back on monday
and i called my brother i said hey you
want to go with me and he's like
yeah i got some work to do i get some
tests next week
and then he says he goes hey have you
had
any tests yet like a calculus test that
was
my first year of calculus and i i said
no we we have one next week
and then he like immediately like cursed
at me yelled at me
and basically said what the hell are you
doing i mean you've never been good at
this
you have this motivation to like change
your path in life
and you're thinking about going to a
frat party and spending the weekend
at a at a frat house and i go yeah well
you know the tests at the end of the
week i'll study on uh
you know when i get back he says to me
goes you should be doing every
single problem in every chapter
multiple times until you can't stand it
anymore
because that's what it's going to take
and i
remember thinking to myself i'm not too
sure i'm going to listen to him i
actually really wanted to go
to this frat party and but i decided
he had gotten good grades through high
school and was doing very well
where he was in college and i thought
well maybe i'll listen to my twin
brother after he was yelling and cursing
at me
on the phone and uh yeah i did what he
said
and then at the end of the week i took
the test and i got 100.
and then from then on i basically knew
what it took
to do well and that is for me what has
always taken
for me is just know as much as you can
about anything you're doing
and then even if you fall a little bit
short
you're still not gonna fall so far that
you're failing
or doing poorly yeah
that story also makes me think of
someone i know named jersey gregoric
he's a polish
born olympic weightlifting champion has
a few world
records and his expression is easy
choices hard life
hard choices easy life so
i mean flashing back choosing to
do those problem sets three four times
instead of going to the frat party i
mean that's sort of a
seems like a defining example of the
hard choice
at least the emotionally hard choice i'd
like to ask you about
failure and how you relate to failure
that's i'm going to
take a take a left turn because i know
you've spoken a lot about space
this doesn't have to be space specific
it could be related to it of course but
how has a how would you say
a failure or a parent failure has set
you up
for later success in other words do you
have any
favorite failure in retrospect
that in some respect kind of planted the
seeds
for a greater success later well you
know
failure is an option i think it's uh
something that we all
probably experience and hopefully we
learn
from it and and move forward certainly
my early education was one big failure
after another
i'm not proud of that wish i could have
a do-over it's actually one of the
greatest regrets of my life
and that is sitting in class for 13
years
not paying attention you know talk about
a colossal waste of time
i wish i could have a do-over on that
you know other failures that would set
me up for success
the first time i qualified to land an
f-14
tomcat on the ship i disqualified
my first landing the hook of the
airplane the tail hook
actually hit the back of the aircraft
carrier the stern
you know the part that goes down towards
the water and
uh i was one and done on that sent home
you know had a stern talking to i was
given an option of
actually going to fly a cargo plane that
the
commanding officer thought well maybe
that would be easier for me
because my first experience at the ship
was so ugly but
you know i was given another chance and
uh
you know in this situation i just
thought to myself
i'd never flown a big airplane before
didn't even know if i could do that but
i thought you know if i'm going to fail
at something
i might as well fail at something that i
think i might not be able to do
rather than say that's easier because at
least this way
you kind of know what you're where you
stand like what you're capable of
i always feel like if we're not always
moving that bar
higher and risking failure
then we're not really reaching our
potential
and the people i've come across not only
at nasa in the military and
industry are the people that are really
successful
are the people that are willing to take
the risk of failing
and oftentimes i'll come across kids or
adults that they don't want to do
something because they think they might
not be able to do it
but what if they are able to they would
never know
so to put yourself out there to expose
yourself
to failure i think is something that
everyone
should strive for because if they don't
they're never going to be able to see
what they could possibly
achieve now hopefully the the
risk-taking i'm talking about is not
something that would get you killed it
almost got me killed on a number of
occasions but
uh yeah hopefully it's not those kind of
risks but
career risk you know other kind of risks
and putting yourself
out there for maybe getting a degree you
don't think you're capable of
applying for a job you think you might
not get those kind of risks or something
i think people should be
challenging themselves like that all the
time it makes me think of
this quote from larry page one of the
co-founders of google
that i'm paraphrasing here but he often
observes that
something that's easy to miss is that if
you aim really big it's
quite difficult to fail completely now
there are examples
certainly within the context of flying
where that
does not apply but in a lot of these
other areas like you mentioned career
decisions etc
even if you fail meaning you don't reach
your objective there can be a lot of
carryover
benefits that you don't get if you aim
really small but let's go back to the
f14 tomcat how
fast are you moving when
you land such a plan i know it's
variable because it's changing
as you're on the approach but yeah
what's the range of speed
as you're my understanding is the f-14
tomcat is about 50 feet wide
and how wide is the aircraft carrier or
the landing portion
i'm not sure how wide the landing area
is but it's not much wider than the
airplane
you don't have a whole lot of margin the
airplane lands it depends on the weight
what weight you're landing at but it's
somewhere around 150
miles an hour not the fastest landing on
on the ship you have to land relatively
slow the t-38 that we flew at nasa
would land at like 170 knots
so the f-14 is a little bit slower but
the thing about the tomcat or any
airplane that's landing on the ship
is not only are you trying to land on
this very small runway
but that runway is constantly moving up
and down
heaving up and down it's pitching bow to
stern it's rolling left to right
and it's uh moving away from you because
the deck is angled as the ship is going
forward so and then sometimes it's dark
so you can't really see anything either
so it's uh it's pretty challenging
piloting task
actually it's it's harder than landing
on the space shuttle
believe it or not difference with the
space shuttle is
you're not feeling well you're dizzy you
might be nauseous
you don't have a second chance uh in
that it's a glider
a big glider with a very poor flying
qualities
and you're only going to get to do this
once or twice in your life you know
everyone's watching you so it's a lot of
a lot of pressure
different kind of pressure in the f-14
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the hour
body this is more than 10 years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard pressed
to find a more nutrient dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once
or twice a day just to make sure i've
covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support
so make an investment in your health
today and try the ultimate all-in-one
wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim you'll receive up
to a year's supply of vitamin d for free
with your first subscription purchase
again
that's athleticgreens.com tim
aside from your own books
uh what what are the books
that you've given the most as gifts to
other people and why do any come to mind
that you've
given to more than one person i'm
looking on my bookshelf
in my office here you know certainly the
right stuff
i've given that to people uh
shackleton's
or alfred lansing's book endurance
which is uh partly where the name of my
book endurance comes from because
that book about ernest shackleton and
his
voyage with his crew of endurance the
ship
to the antarctic in the uh beginning of
the
last century was really one of the
greatest examples of
leadership in a very challenging and
dangerous environment that i could
ever imagine i mean it's just
extraordinary
what shackleton as the leader of that
expedition was able to do when their
ship endurance got stuck in the ice
eventually
crushed and they spent
i forget exactly how long but it was
almost like two years
saving themselves that involved you know
living on ice packs
and transits of hundreds and hundreds of
miles and lifeboats
in the arctic a uh crossing of south
georgia island in the winter
that no one had ever done before but
shackleton and a small team of
his guys did that as at the end of them
trying to save themselves and he was
able to do that
and no one died
none of his crew members died everyone
survived
that book is very meaningful book for me
that i have actually given it to other
people
hemingway fans certainly uh you know the
old man
in the sea is a favorite and i'm also
looking at uh
pearl bucks the good earth i think i've
given that book to other people
what is the good earth about yeah so
it's about uh
pearl box the gird earth it's it's
brilliant it's about this guy named uh
this farmer in china this peasant farmer
that i haven't read in a long time but i
think his name was wang long
he goes from peasant farmer and survives
all these famines and
eventually becomes a major land holder
really a great book incredibly well
written and a uh
great example of like what life was like
in that time during china
before the revolution and when they had
many many years of famine and you know
having massive numbers of people having
to migrate
as a result highly recommended one of my
favorites of all time
that is a nonfiction or fiction it's
non-fiction
let's talk about scientific literacy for
a few minutes
yeah so so i am not a scientist
i support a lot of science i have a
basic
level of i would consider it scientific
literacy
there is a lot of froth and noise
out in the the world today certainly
magnified
by social media and so on in many
respects
could you speak to what happened with
respect to
steph curry and the moon landing
except this may be an entry point for
discussing how people can develop
the greater ability to separate fact
from fiction
i'll tell you what i'm not a scientist
either although i do play one on tv
occasionally in space i do other
a lot of people think hey you're an
astronaut you must be a scientist no
i'm not a scientist i've i've done a lot
of science i think i'm a science-minded
person
i know what science is i know what it
isn't
and unfortunately i think in today's
society a lot of people have
lost their reality in some ways
where all of a sudden in our society
like science is now
opinion or politics it's not
it's subjective observation it's
evidence it's experimentation
it's critical analysis it's peer review
it's always evolving but it is the truth
as we know it
at that particular time the science
deniers we have in our society now are
dangerous it's like
i used to kind of goof around with the
the flat earthers
now i don't even like acknowledge their
existence and i probably shouldn't even
brought them up because i don't believe
that they should even be given any kind
of
acknowledgement because it's just so
absolutely outrageous
it's like if you're a flat earther why
don't you just deny that the sun is in
the sky i mean
the earth is round i mean you can go up
in an airplane
and look out the window and see that
it's round
you got to look pretty closely because
you're not very high but if you do look
closely
you can see we lived on a curved planet
not to mention
that you know thousands of years of
science has determined
that the earth is round and of course
i've seen it from space and it is pretty
round
it's not flat it was and if it was flat
wouldn't the edge be like the most
popular tourist attraction
on earth i would just go set up a like a
taco truck and
you know make a billion dollars
with my uh you know edge of the earth
tacos
yeah so i generally don't give those
kind of folks
any acknowledgement because i just think
it's so outrageous
and i know some of them do it kind of as
a goof and they think it's funny or it's
cute or whatever
you know some people really believe it
the danger is
if you're willing to believe that the
earth is flat what else are you willing
to believe
that vaccines don't work that we are not
living in
a pandemic where people by the thousands
are dying every day throughout
you know around the world that climate
change
is a hoax so it's a it's a risky thing
you know with regards to steph steph is
an awesome guy i think he's a smart guy
i think in his situation he just kind of
got caught up in one
in a thing where he said he just agreed
with somebody about the moon landings
probably would not even give it a whole
lot of thought
and then he got a lot of heat for it and
i felt bad for him because i like him
i'm a fan
so i just reached out to him and i said
hey you know if you want to talk about
the moon landing i'd be happy to
share what i know with you and he was
very
happy to have that conversation and to
take back his
what he said about that because and i
and he did he he wasn't doing anything
malicious he was just kind of agreeing
with the guy
a guy who said that and he was kind of
on to the next thing but
a lot of people gave him a lot of heat
for it so we'd a little talk about i
think
he understands now if we look at the
spectrum
of let's just call it scientific
not scientific thinking but sort of
detached
on some level rational skepticism etc
the ability to navigate the world and to
the best of our ability separate
fact from fiction it does
seem to me that there are people out
there who are not let's just say flat
earthers right or
or people who are trying to convince you
of god knows what that is just
it seems clearly at face value
ridiculous to the people in the middle
who
really don't know how to best
discern what is true and what is not and
i think vaccines are a great example
uh in the sense that i have many friends
who i would consider
in many many domains to be very smart
high performing effective people who do
not even know where to begin
with vaccines just in terms of
claims from friends certainly
different sites on the their facebook
friends that are claiming to be experts
on this stuff
yeah or they or those facebook friends
link to a site that seems to have
citations and they just
i mean i will i will just say like these
people i'm talking about some of them
are not
they're not people i would consider
broadly stupid people at all
so how can someone who wants to become
more discerning
and capable in sifting through
the noise become better tuned do you
have any suggestions for how
they can cultivate that yeah absolutely
i mean
i'm not an expert on many many things
you know there are things that i know a
lot about things i don't know a whole
lot of
about but when i don't know about those
i ask the rocket scientist of whatever
that thing is i get my information
from trusted sources government agencies
that
are the authority on the pandemic like
the cdc the world health organization
these kind of places media outlets that
you know have been there for a long time
and that have a reputation
not your crazy uncle on facebook not
people you've never heard of so it's
just shocking to me
that people will just discount
things that are the truth without
even trying to go find out what the real
story is
and just saying well i i just don't
believe i don't believe that i don't
believe that
yeah you don't have to be a scientist to
understand
science and even if you don't understand
it you know find the person that's the
expert
and believe them because they're the
experts right
let's talk about something that you are
i would think
very qualified to comment on and that is
possible future missions to mars i would
love to just hear
your thoughts on the feasibility or
attractiveness of future missions to
mars
in part because there are many diverging
opinions here you have for instance you
have elon musk on one
side of the spectrum you have then
also people like jeff bezos who i
believe have publicly said you know the
last thing you want to do is have to
deal with
gravity and the environment on mars like
once you get into space
you want to build communities in space
as opposed to
on another planet for a host of
different reasons and if you
you mentioned shackleton so if you like
the idea of being on mars you should try
living in
antarctica for a few months and then
let me know how you feel since that's
pretty temperate and
forgiving compared to the ecosystem on
mars or the climate at least
how would you suggest people think about
or how do you think about
uh missions to mars yeah so you know a
few things come to mind you know one and
one is that i'll i'll quote my brother
and give him credit for this because he
said it and that's the only place i've
ever heard this
and he says going to mars is not about
rocket science
it's really about political science
because
you know we know much of what we need to
know technically about how to do it but
if we're going to really do that someday
put people
put boots on mars it's really more about
having the money the
political support and the public support
it's gonna take
people to vote in to office
you know science-minded people that feel
like this is important
you know i do think we can do it we
could probably do it pretty soon there
are some challenges i think we need
better lives
you know our life support systems
probably need to be a little bit
more robust we certainly have to protect
the crew from
radiation whether we have some
protective materials or we just get
to mars quicker so they're not exposed
to radiation for that long but it's
something that we're absolutely capable
of doing and i think we should do
i don't think though we need to look at
mars as a lifeboat
for planet earth now i say that
having been wrong about things that elon
has said before so
you know when he was going to land his
the first stage of the falcon rocket on
a ship and reuse it
my initial thought was he's crazy but
then he went and did it
and he did it again and again and again
and again
so i will never say elon's crazy again
but i always think it'll be easier to
live
on earth regardless of what bad thing
might happen to it
and i also think it's important that we
need to recognize that
really this is our home we need to take
care of it we're not going to move the
whole planet to mars i think it's
important to go to mars
and you know establish a foothold it's
great that we've had a foothold in space
we're coming up on the 20-year
anniversary
of having people in space continuously
so
kids that are alive today have never
been on planet earth with everybody else
and i think we should continue to do
that i think we should go to mars
someday
i think we should have people living on
mars but i don't look at it as a
plan b necessary as a planet b kind of
thing yeah i do think
you know this planet could be pretty
well destroyed
and i don't think we should do that but
it could be and it would still be easier
than living
on mars living here what are the most
compelling arguments for the importance
of getting people
to mars or more simply asked why do you
think it is important
because it would involve of course very
significant cost
yeah i i think going to mars is you know
it's going to be expensive but that
expense is paid
with uh you know very
high high-paying jobs that recently
there was this nasa study that talked
about the return on investment so
you know nasa is a money-making prospect
in that
it generates more tax dollars than it it
uses
a mission to mars would be the same
thing but mr mars would develop
technologies that
we may not have today maybe it won't i
don't know it may it may not
it'll definitely push our envelope of
what we are technically capable of doing
i think it would be a great way to
cooperate internationally you know we
have a lot of conflict here on earth
but we've been flying on that space
station with the russians for
the last 20 years and it gives countries
that are
sometimes in conflict with each other a
place to work on something that is
peaceful that benefits everybody
i think that we're explorers i think
it's in our nature our dna i don't think
we would have developed
to be the species we are today if we
didn't
explore i think it's part of who we are
and we should continue to do it
and then i think if everything i said
was wrong the fact that
that kind of mission that going to mars
going to the moon
the space station the space shuttle the
space program in general
it inspires kids not only in the united
states
but around the world to be better
students
to study math and science and stem
careers
to be better at those
in those areas of study that are so
so important to our economy because all
those people all those kids around the
world that
are so inspired by nasa they're not
going to work for nasa i mean some of
them will but all of them aren't
you know they're going to go into other
fields that contribute to our economy
our society and our way of life and if
that's all we got out of it that's worth
every penny i mean if the
six or s whatever billion dollars we
spend a year on human space flight
if the only thing we got out of that is
that kind of inspiration for our kids
which i don't think it's the only thing
we get out of it
but if it was worth every cent here here
thank you for that answer let's talk
about
go for launch so subtitle how to dream
lead and achieve this is your two hour
audio course
on knowable why did you
produce this audio course and what do
you hope people will
gain from it you know i think you know
my my life story has a lot of
lessons in it that i think will
help other people and inspire other
people that they can do things that
maybe they didn't think they were
capable
of they can take risks they can
challenge themselves they can
i'm hoping that people will look at this
as a way to
find maybe more success in their own
lives and
i've done that with the public speaking
i do i've done it with
the books that i've written and this is
just a new way
of reaching a different audience i
didn't really didn't know much about
noble before i was approached to do this
but when i learned about it i was like
hey that's a really good idea you know
people like to listen to books on tape
now especially a lot more recently and
why not listen to something that is not
a book but
has a you know particular lessons
from different kinds of people so for
those
that don't know knowables it's a it's a
new app
that gives exclusive audio courses from
different types of experts chris paul is
one of them alexis
ohanian me a bunch of
other people it's basically kind of like
listening to uh
spotify but it's for learning something
and uh
you know hopefully people will learn
something that will help in their lives
from
the audio course i was able to put
together they can
find this course on knowable dot
fyi forward slash
scott at least that's what they told me
uh
where you can find it and i hope i said
that right
and uh yeah i hope people enjoy it
there's some some humor in there
i tell a couple of jokes every now and
then i hope people find them funny
and uh hope they enjoy it and we'll link
to that also for everybody in the show
notes since that's heavily trafficked at
tim dot blog
forward slash tim so we'll link to
everything including noble.fyi
scott for folks just uh maybe two more
questions
and then we can bring this round one
to a close wait round one there's
a round two i always want you know i
like saying round one
i could say this conversation but if it
gives you
more anxiety that you enjoy i could say
this is round one of 17
to the forthcoming indefinite series
with scott kelly no this is
this is the end of the conversation
right so i always like to say round one
just just in case there is a round two
emerald right there when you said
i'm out understandable understandable
so two questions the first is and these
are sometimes
dead ends and i'll take the blame if
they are but we'll give it a shot so the
first is
if you could put anything on a
gigantic billboard this is
metaphorically speaking to get a message
or a question an image anything out to
billions of people
what might you put on that something
non-commercial
right now i'd say something like science
is real
believe it yeah science is real
believe it yeah what a world we live in
yeah right you you're to yeah imagine
galileo coming or newton coming to this
uh this world now they would lose their
minds
yeah the i saw a cartoon at the
beginning of the
pandemic which featured this guy clearly
that's sort of the
husband and wife couple and the
husband's sitting at his computer and he
says honey it's amazing
last week all of my friends on facebook
were constitutional
lawyers and this week they're all
epidemiologists yeah right
so search for the signal folks all right
the second question
is and this might seem like a bizarre
question
but i'm curious when is the last time
you cried tears of joy
that you remember this might be a answer
you're not expecting or weird but i
don't think i ever have
maybe uh ever yeah i don't think so
tears of joy yeah yeah
i'm not i'm not i'm not much of a crier
there's no crying in space
no crying in space no crying in baseball
people all right
well scott is there anything uh that you
would like to say just as closing
comments
any recommendations or asks of the
audience you would like
to add before we close well you know
certainly i think you know having this
platform and an opportunity to speak to
your
viewers and that is we're living in some
really crazy times right now
and uh i've had the privilege to see
people work
in some really challenging environments
in uh
things that that are very risky things
that you might not even believe is
possible and and
we're able to be successful success
requires teamwork and i think our
country just needs to realize that
we just gotta have to start working
together i mean we can't
live in this divided society where
people are in conflict with one another
because we have some serious challenges
and the way you meet those challenges
is with teamwork and that has been my
experience my whole career at nasa
and i just wish more people would just
kind of come together
identify problems do it in a thoughtful
way
believe in science solve those problems
and then move on to the next thing and
i'm just very hopeful that we can get
there
and hopefully get there soon science is
real believe it
and uh this is a great place to end well
scott thank you so much for taking the
time today
i know this is a long-form conversation
and i appreciate you carving out the
time to have
a chat and to share your life lessons
and to answer my
sometimes obvious sometimes peculiar
sometimes in the middle questions
so thank you very much for carving out
some space to do this
hey thanks for having me tim i very much
enjoyed it thank you
and to everybody listening you can find
show notes
links to everything we've discussed at
tim dot blog forward slash
podcast you can find the noble course at
for noble.fyi.fords.com and until next
time thanks for tuning in
i'm grateful that throughout my 20 years
at nasa i had the chance to work with a
wide variety of people from different
backgrounds
i flew in space with a french engineer a
school teacher from idaho
a swiss astrophysicist and more russian
cosmonauts than i can count
he spoke different languages believed
different things
problem solved in different ways and
when you're trying to do something as
challenging as flying in space
you need as many different strengths as
you can get
and then i met katie
when i was preparing for my first
long-duration space flight
i was slated to overlap for a majority
of the 159 days
with katie coleman katie was a military
officer
in the air force a chemist she was a
veteran of two space shuttle missions
just like
me but katie and i were as different as
two military officers can be
in fact some of our colleagues were
seriously concerned that we might kill
each other
for months we would have to cooperate
and live together in a space the size of
the inside of a 747
filled with stuff so when katie first
arrived
i could see why people had been worried
katie didn't entirely live her life by
schedules
and i would often find her in the little
window filled module called the cupola
looking at the earth and playing her
flute at three o'clock in the morning
[Music]
throughout the workday i always knew
what katie was working on because she
would leave experiments and projects
half done
or there would be scraps and remnants of
her activities
just floating around i used to call it a
katy trail
but whatever else she needed to do katie
always made time to speak with people on
the ground
especially school children even beyond
the many events that nasa schedules us
for
hi my name is shake and my question is
how do you dispose trash
on the space station chick you have an
excellent question for exactly
this week it is very difficult we can't
just she made time for art
and music even playing the first earth
space duet on her flute with the founder
of the band
jethro tull
[Music]
it was one more aspect of our
personalities that couldn't be more
different
i had always seen the public relations
part of my job as a nuisance
it needed to be done because the public
has a right to know what's being done
with their tax dollars
and to feel involved in the space
program but i'm not a newscaster or
youtuber
and i didn't really enjoy being pressed
into service as one
i felt that my job was to command the
space station
carry out the many complex procedures
and experiments i was tasked with
to run a tight ship to keep my crew safe
and obviously to keep everything from
exploding
one day we had a standard public affairs
interview here's what i sounded like
answering questions in my factual
straightforward are we done yet tone
we got up here about a little over a
hundred and
something days ago not that i'm counting
but uh felt like i picked up just where
i left off last time
this was not my favorite part of the day
later
katie confronted me she said you know if
you don't sound excited about what we're
doing up here
no one else will be either she was right
i learned a lot by watching katie and by
the time i flew a year-long mission on
the space station
you could certainly hear the difference
and you actually packed a gorilla suit
in your gear which is incredible
you know it's it's interesting when you
vacuum pack something it doesn't take up
a whole lot of room
and uh you know for one when you try to
get kids attention
and and teach them about science and
math and engineering and things like
that
the first thing you have to do is get
their attention and nothing gets
people's attention like a gorilla in
space
by this time i'd figured out twitter and
instagram
i've been building up the year in space
hashtag i did it read in ama
i showed off the first flower we grew in
space i played water ping pong
and had a super bowl party for one i
juggled fruit
which is still impressive even though
the fruit just kind of hangs there
i also explained how i had to clean up a
gallon-sized ball of urine and acid
i explained that space smells like
burning metal and that my favorite david
bowie song
is not space oddity but probably
under pressure
[Music]
it wasn't what i thought i had been
trained for but this kind of work was
able to bring
all kinds of people into the experience
of our mission
and bring them closer to science
engineering and the amazing things we
accomplished when we all worked together
but it was katie with her flute and her
always positive attitude that made that
possible
we all learned a lot from each other up
there in training to fly on the russian
spacecraft i spent a lot of time in
russia
getting to know the culture and learning
to speak the language not very well i
might add
i've had the chance to get to know
russian literature and history in a way
i never expected
there's always potential for conflict
and challenges particularly with the
russians
our countries are not always the
friendliest i guess you could call us
frenemies
but in space you set all that aside
because we rely on those cosmonauts
and they rely on us space is a great
place to do that
because no one owns it it's a common
ground where peaceful scientific
collaboration can occur
i've learned from my colleagues who grew
up in different cultures
practice different religions and were
born with different sexual orientations
it's only been very recently that nasa
has recruited astronauts who openly
acknowledge a same-sex partner and i
hope to see a transgender
astronaut in my lifetime
i have a transgender son who is one of
the smartest and kindest people i have
ever had the privilege of knowing and it
would be a loss to nasa if they didn't
choose to include people like him among
the ranks someday
in retrospect i think the people who
told katie and me we would kill each
other in space
underestimated both of us and overlook
the power of our differences
i try to keep this in mind when i see
people who seem very different working
together
and i want to encourage them to see
their differences as strengths
and what we refer to in the military as
a force multiplier
katie and i are now lifelong friends and
when i think of the mission we flew
together
i hope she remembers as fondly as i do
the times i'd find her playing her flute
in the cupola
and couldn't help but tell her katie
go to sleep it's a school night i don't
care if you're friends with jethro tall
[Music]
sometimes people are incentivized to
dodge blame or even cover up their
mistakes
and i've seen this in action as well the
russian space agency has a very
different way of managing and
compensating their cosmonauts than nasa
does its astronauts
and part of that has to do with how
blame is distributed
both astronauts and cosmonauts are paid
extra when they are flying in space
in the case of the cosmonauts they get a
significant bonus of somewhere between
350 to 700 us dollars per day
depending on how experienced they are so
for someone like my friend gennady who
has spent 879 days in space
that can really add up by contrast
american astronauts are paid the
government per diem rate
five dollars per day but our salaries
are much higher to begin with
which means we are less dependent on
that bonus for our livelihoods than the
cosmonauts are
which is where the problem comes in
[Music]
cosmonauts are given higher bonuses for
their achievements
like a successful spacewalk and lower
bonuses to reflect mistakes
for flipping the wrong switch missing a
step in an experiment
or similar everyday human errors
and you might not believe this but
there's actually a real person
in russian mission control whose only
job is to track the mistakes of
cosmonauts
and when each cosmonaut comes back to
earth they have to sit in a room with
the mistake tracker and an accountant
to determine what their bonus is going
to be
[Music]
i've experienced firsthand the way this
sort of negotiation is supposed to work
when i was preparing to fly on the
russian soyuz spacecraft
i trained with my crewmates in a
simulator much like the simulators i've
trained on in houston to fly the space
shuttle
after our final simulation flights in
russia
we would have to answer to a panel of
russian space agency officials about our
performance
kind of a public stoning i would call it
it took me a while to understand that we
were actually expected to create an
elaborate excuse matrix about how we
hadn't done anything wrong
how everything was somebody else's fault
and that no blame should be attached to
us
i came to think of this practice as
blame smithing
and some people were quite skilled at it
bending the narrative of events to
always move the blame away from you
and towards some other poor bastard
[Music]
i was terrible at this but that was fine
with me and i think it annoyed the
russians that during the public stoning
when it was my turn to make an
impassioned speech about how i didn't
flip the wrong switch
i just say yep that was me
now once we were in space the question
of blame got real for my russian friends
they were always dealing with the
possibility of losing their income to
the smallest mistakes
so i tell them to blame me as far as i
could see it it was a win-win
they wouldn't lose their bonus and their
control center wouldn't spend a day
trying to figure out what went wrong
because they were avoiding
responsibility
real teamwork means it's crucial for
everyone to admit their mistakes
if you want to solve problems move fast
and make sure everyone's doing their
best
you can't punish people for speaking up
that's true in space
but it applies anytime anywhere in my
experience as a space shuttle crew
member and later as commander of the
international space station
i learned how important this was on the
space shuttle
if i had actuated the wrong switch at
the wrong moment always a possibility
with 2
000 of them i might have caused 100
people in mission control to spend hours
or even days
trying to figure out why their data
looked funny and not focusing on what is
important
it's so much better to just be honest
and move on and if that doesn't work you
can always say
the american didn't hey guys this is tim
again just a few more things before you
take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and
five bullet friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things
i've found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by 99 designs
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for you to find and work with
amazing graphic designers online
long time listeners of this podcast know
how much attention i paid to detail
how obsessively i approach nearly all
elements of my work
because the small things often end up
being the big thing so whether it's your
logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about
so i think it's worth sweating the
details i've been using 99designs for
years now
to ensure that many of my creative
projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer at 99designs to update the
illustrations and layouts for all of my
downloadable ebooks
i've developed a really great working
relationship with designer who goes by
the username spoon and i intend to
continue working with him to bring ideas
to life one project
at a time i've also used 99 designs for
all sorts
of high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites packaging to
books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long term work you can also book a
free design consultation with a brand
expert at 99designs to receive
personalized branding advice over the
phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point it's a
great way to get the most out of your
experience with 99designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com tim
for your discount to sign up for design
consultation today
that's 99designs.com tim
this episode is brought to you by
rockform that's without a c
rokform rokform is the active lifestyle
iphone and galaxy
protective case company i've been using
their stuff
for a few months now and good god
they can survive anything first off
rokform protection is beyond great you
can find thousands of five star reviews
and customer testimonials which the team
at rock farm calls survival stories that
include
things like a drop from the upper deck
of a baseball stadium and a 75 foot cell
phone tower fall
it's kind of unbelievable but these
cases make your phone
virtually indestructible each case is
built also around an integrated magnet
that is completely safe for your phone
the magnets are incredibly strong and
allow you to instantly attach your
device to any magnetic surface
toolboxes file cabinets refrigerators
golf carts
you name it i use it in the gym to check
my form all out of the time you can just
slap it on just about anything rokform
pioneered magnetic technology in the
mobile accessory space in 2011
and i've never seen anything quite like
these magnets
i will use mine on my peloton bike so i
can watch listen or take calls during
workouts
it fits my iphone 11 pro max perfectly
and allows me to keep my hands free for
all sorts of stuff
all their cases also come with a
built-in twist lock system that can be
used with any of rock farms optional
mounts
for bike motorcycle car and much more
these machined aluminum mounts are built
to last and are compatible with every
rokform case
so if you get a new phone or whatever
you just need a new
case and it will still attach to all of
the mounts
rokform also has a portable golf speaker
this is bluetooth
that instantly mounts to a golf cart
with mind-blowingly
strong magnets like i mentioned i don't
really golf
but i will use this bluetooth speaker to
listen to music
in the kitchen i'll slap it on the
refrigerator i will
use it in the gym and hang it from a
carabiner which is included
with the speaker and so on and so forth
so
upgrade to a rokform case today because
you have better things to hold on
you can use your hands for other stuff
and like i mentioned
these things make your phone bulletproof
and as a special offer for tim ferris
show listeners that's you guys
get 25 off that is a good discount 25
off at rockform.com that's rokform.com
when you use promo code 10 that's 25 off
at rokform.com when you use promo code
tim one more time rockform.com promo
code
[Applause]
tip
you